اين وصلت جهود اجلاء الدول مواطنيها من
السودان حتى الان القاهره اجلت سته الاف
وثلاثمائه وتسعه وتسعين مصريا في المجمل
وقالت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه ان نحو 16
الف شخص عبر الحدود من السودان الى مصر
بينهم 14 الف سودانيه بينما نقلت مهمه
اجلاء المانيه 500 شخص في المجمل من اكثر
من 30 دوله من بينها بلجيكا وبريطانيا
وهولندا والاردن وقالت الحكومه الفرنسيه
انها اجلت
936 شخصا من السودان بينهم 400 من موظف
الامم المتحده وعائلاتهم
في حين اجلت طائرات عسكريه ايطاليه اقلعت
من جيبوتي 83 ايطاليا و13 اخرين بينهم
اطفال وسفير الايطالي
وافادت بريطانيا بانها اجلت
897 شخصا من السودان على ثمان رحلات جويه
بريطانيه حتى يوم الخميس الماضي وانه
سيكون هناك المزيد من الرحلات ومن جانبها
قلت هولندا انه تم اجلاء نحو 100 هولندي
من السودان منذ يوم الاحد بينما نقلت كندا
اكثر من 100 شخص منهم كنديون وجنسيات اخرى
في رحلتين جويتين من السودان
وافادت الصين بانها نقلت نحو 800 شخص عن
طريق البحر كما نصحت مواطنيها بالدخول عبر
ميناء جده الاسلامي ومن جانبها تواصل
السعوديه عملياتها الانسانيه لاجلاء
رعاياها ومواطني دول اخرى من السودان اذ
ارتفع عدد من تم اجلائهم حتى الان الى نحو
4879 شخصا منهم 139 مواطنا واربعه الاف
وسبعمائه
ينتمون لسبع وتسعين جنسيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات